this slack line is less than two inches
wide over
170 feet long and hundreds of feet above
a canyon floor it may be terrifying for
the most of us but for this woman it's
exactly where she wants to be
my name is faith dickey i'm a
professional slackliner highliner and
guide
even getting over a fear of heights it's
not nearly as easy as it seems every
detail has to be considered
speed of the wind
placement of her feet tension on the
rope it all matters if you want to make
it to the other side when i'm on the
high line i often make micro adjustments
with my wrist sometimes i really focus
on what my fingers feel like how the
wind feels as it's blowing past them
when i actually walked a line
successfully it was sort of like seeing
color for the first time i mean my mind
was blown
[Music]
i actually got all these crazy muscles
in my feet that most people don't have
these are all balance muscles that we
just don't get to use in everyday life
that's not the only thing that makes her
different from the rest of us
she's built a life in this death defying
world breaking countless world records
faith became the first woman to cross a
high line over 100 meters long in 2014
and she also broke the record for
longest free solo in 2012 in the czech
republic which means she did it without
a safety harness i was the reigning
world record for women in the sport of
slacklining and highlining for about six
years undefeated it was pretty
incredible i just was so focused and so
obsessed i just wanted to accomplish
things for myself and on accident set
world records and on accident became a
pioneer
[Music]
if i look down on a high line i'm seeing
everything all at once my feet the
exposure below me it feels impossible to
focus on one tiny thing it's just kind
of a mind-blowing overload of
information for my brain i love that
feeling
when i'm standing on a high line out in
space
so much of the experience is about the
sky and just how big the sky is above me
[Music]
this kind of balance and control didn't
just come naturally faith had to fall a
lot to get to where she is today the
first time you set foot on a slackline
it's really crazy how wobbly the line is
it's really hard to commit to actually
putting your full body weight on there
because you feel like you're just gonna
get thrown off there's so much falling
involved and i think you really have to
get over that hump of failure to keep
going to see your success
i fought so hard i fell so many times
i fell over and over and over again i
was black and blue covered in bruises
and then finally i somehow just locked
in
stood up on that high line and step by
step
made it across
[Music]
people have been testing the limits of
their balance for centuries on beams
tightropes and more it's a tradition
that spans continents and cultures from
circus performers to olympic athletes
but in the 1980s a group of rock
climbers found a new way to pass the
time when they started balancing on
stretchy ropes and webbing and that's
when slacklining was born
while tightrope walking is usually done
on a high tension metal wire a slack
line has more give and more bounce
almost like a narrow trampoline
the result is an extremely dynamic form
of balanced movement
and just like every part of the sport
details really matter how phase sets up
the line can mean the difference between
life and death so if i'm setting up a
high line for the first time in an area
that's never had a high line before
where there's nothing to anchor off of
like a boulder or a tree i'll be placing
bolts in the rock i equalize off of at
least three different points slacklines
are typically made from nylon polyester
i use steel carabiners i try to use all
steel in my system i have a special
device called a line grip which has two
rubber plates that grip the slack line
so i can pull it and tighten it the
other thing that's really important when
rigging high lines is lots of padding
one of the biggest risks for breaking a
line is rock abrasion i have these kind
of velcro sleeves that i wrap all the
rope and all the slackline with on the
edges i only want to go highlining with
people i trust if my friend is on the
other side of the canyon building an
anchor i want to know that they're going
to do it safely i want to live a long
life i don't have a death wish it's
really about understanding what the
risks are mitigating them and then
accepting that there's risk involved
there's a science to this stuff a short
slack line doesn't have much movement
because the anchor points are close
together because of that the line
doesn't have much give and each step
lands in a similar place to the last
just one step in front of the other
it's far harder to stay balanced on a
longer line that has sag and sway it
means you're going downhill and then
uphill while the wind is moving you when
a line gets longer and heavier it's much
harder to walk the line is tightest at
the anchor where it's attached to the
rock or the tree but as you walk that
tension gets looser and looser and the
middle is the loosest part the hardest
part of a high line is at the very end
because you're walking uphill so your
feet are slipping a little bit and it's
much more exertion and all you want to
do is get on that rock because of the
dynamic nature of the slack line each
step is different from the last faiths
approach to this challenge means being
in precise control of her body
i'm trying to keep my heartbeat very
slow and calm on the high line
i can feel each little twitch in my
finger as i find equilibrium
i can feel exactly what it's like when
the soul of my foot touches the line and
rolls forward
but faith didn't always plan on being a
highlining master she wanted to go into
fashion but life had a different plan
for her when i was 18 i fell asleep
driving my car and flipped it over the
car crash was
terrifying and it made me do a 180 in my
life i suddenly was faced with
who am i and how do i want to live my
life i needed to take some time to
really figure all that out and
slacklining was a catalyst
catalyst is an understatement her mental
toughness and love for the sport quickly
made her a star
soon came the magazine articles
sponsorships and offers to travel the
world teaching and establishing new
routes i kind of inadvertently became a
pioneer in the sport especially for
women and along with some people who i
was on a team with we established so
many lines around the world we took
slacklining and highlining to places
where it never existed before
it takes years of experience to stand on
a high line and quickly tune your body
to match the ever-changing character of
the line
i might shift my hips
i'm trying to keep my back straight our
vision is super important you go where
you look if i want to make it more
challenging i look around but if i want
to be as concentrated and stable as
possible i focus on one point and that's
where i walk to
as my foot comes down and makes contact
with the slackline there's a specific
place i put it i don't wrap my toes
around it it's really just about
centering my foot on top of it if i make
contact with the line a little bit to
the side there's the potential that when
i weight that foot i'm gonna slip off
the line and so i have to adjust
immediately
the other part that's super key is
breathing
i like to think of my breath traveling
through my body i imagine it traveling
through my arms and out of my fingertips
traveling through my torso down into my
feet into the line it's how i calm my
body down
it's not just about winning world titles
and having all the right gear faith
models her life on the lessons she's
learned from slacklining and highlining
i think in the moment that you're
engaging with fear of death it becomes
really clear what's important in life
being on a high line and really engaging
with that fear step by step it taught me
that i can live beyond that fear it
doesn't have to stop me from
accomplishing the things i want to do
[Music]